Vung kiếm, phát gẩy mô sông tiếp con, cả các bỏ sình nghĩ,
Rồi bóc ín đi chí đều diễn đổi luyện trên gà la zào thửa chú quốc.
Thế một mang tên của Bốt, Rồi Bốt của ín đi chí Rồi Bó tích,
đều diễn cùng học viên trên bó thật tà của Hà Nam trên sống gà la zào thửa
tối mùi sảo tăng hải, bối các phá nhau lộn và đánh đối khán theo đổi hình.
Có đoạn Rồi Bốt, tại hiện tuy quyền của tình lào nào đi đang xây dầu,
ngã người ra sau dù mặt dậy còn gặng tiếp tục mặt chính diễn.
Theo CCTV, e-kit bắt đầu trình bị từ tăng mùi mô t năm 2019,
đốn nhiều thời gian nhất ở khu trọng đồng tác, sản giữ kịch mạnh và tính chính trình
trên đồng để lên thình bữa trả khất nhạc.
Chức buổi tổng dễ thơ mù tháng, được ki thuật đã đưa đồ bó phỏ trường quay để thu dữ liệu,
và giữa mô hình bà đề cho sân khấu khoảng sảo trong mết vôm.
Rồi bóc dùng lại đã để từ định vì khi trải đoạn.
Em đồng tác phải khớm nhạc tới vải trục viên lý dây và tốt đồ trải vị trí ở tính nhàng hơn